people are making more money they're
finding better jobs and after decades of
being mistreated and paid too little
more and more american workers have real
power now to get better wages
and to do what's best for themselves and
their families
some people see that as a problem we've
had this discussion in the past i don't
i see it as long overdue
so when you hear these numbers they're
not statistics
it's a statement of the type of economy
we're fighting for an economy as i've
been saying from the beginning built
from the bottom up in the middle out not
from the top down
when we do it that way everybody does
well everybody wins
even though we created a record number
of jobs we know i know
that this job is not finished we need to
do more to get prices under control
putin's invasion of ukraine has driven
up gas prices and food prices all over
the world
to help deal with that yesterday i
authorized the release of one million
barrels per day
for the next six months from our
strategic petroleum reserve
acknowledge this by far is the largest
release of our national reserves in our
history
it is a wartime bridge is the way i look
at it to increase our oil supply as we
work with our oil u.s oil producers to
ramp up their production
to get us through this period
i've coordinated this release with
partners and allies around the world
this morning
over 30 countries from across the world
convened in an extraordinary meeting
and agreed to the release of tens of
millions of additional barrels of oil
onto the market
hundreds of hours of meetings with key
allies keeping them together is paying
off
nations are coming together to deny
putin the ability to weaponize his
energy resources against american
families not only american families but
families in europe and around the world
i've also made it a priority to get
america's fiscal house in order
under my predecessor the federal budget
deficit went up every single year
every year
as i committed when i was running this
when i got here we're going to turn that
around
in fact last year in 2021
we cut the federal deficit by more than
350 billion dollars and this year
in 2022 we're on track to cut the
deficit by more than
1.3 trillion dollars
1.3 trillion
that would be the largest one-year
reduction in a deficit in u.s history
and it's particularly important now as
we work to reduce pressures on inflation
that's what happens when you reduce the
deficit so here are the facts
it was the previous administration whose
reckless policies and mismanagement led
to the record budget deficits in my
administration that's getting the
deficit under control in fact i just
released my budget this week and it
shows going forward we can cut the
deficit by another one trillion dollars
over the next decade while still making
prudent investments in economic growth
and climate and other equitable economic
decisions
but to do that
we have to be willing to do something
previous administrations and republicans
today refuse to do
we need to make sure corporations and
the super wealthy begin to pay their
fair share
here's one example
right now billionaires and there's
not a whole lot of them in the country
maybe i won't give a number because i
don't know for sure
they uh they averaged less than one
percent but my point is billionaires pay
an average rate of only eight percent on
their total income
a family
led by a firefighter and a teacher
can pay double that income tax rate
double what did what a billionaire pays
double the eight percent
so my budget has a billionaire minimum
tax a twenty percent minimum tax that
applies only to the top one one
hundredth of one per one hundredth of
one percent
of american households
billionaire minimum tax is fair
and here's the deal
it raises 360 billion dollars
that can be used to lower costs for
families and cut the deficit
it would add it would and i would add
nobody making less than four you're
tired of hearing me say it but no one
making less than 400 000 a year will pay
a single penny more in federal taxes
i've said in the past i'm a capitalist i
have no problem with people making as
much money as they are capable of making
but i'm asking you one simple just pay
your fair share
pay your fair share that's all that's it
just your fair share and no one can
argue
that 20 for a billionaire is unfair
here's what this adds up to
we're going to continue to create jobs
bring down the cost for families and
reign in deficits left by my predecessor
all important steps in our prop
to continue our historic progress to
build a better america
i said from the outset
we're the only country in the world that
comes out of crises stronger than we
were into them
that's what we're doing here i want to
thank you all for showing up today and
we'll have plenty of time to answer
questions about other items other than
the
jobs report next week thank you
appreciate it sir what about inflation
outpacing wages mr president
facing criminal charges are the
sanctions still working sir
you